[Música]
[Aplausos]
hola qué tal bueno buenos días a todos
ya todas nosotros ya nos presentaron
somos tania y rodrigo y venimos a
platicarles una historia sobre un
proyecto que es fruto del amor por el
cine del amor por la libertad de
pensamiento y por la libertad de
creación caleidoscopio taller de vídeo
participativo con niños y niñas y desde
el caleidoscopio nosotros creemos
firmemente que todos tenemos el derecho
a expresarnos libremente pero también
para poder compartir nuestras propias
historias y fueron las historias lo que
a mí me llevaron a estudiar periodismo
sin embargo en los medios tradicionales
nunca me sentí cómoda o más bien nunca
encontré mi lugar y fue hasta que conocí
a rodrigo que me acerque a la
realización audiovisual al cine a la
imagen en movimiento y eso también me
llevó a hacer historias
desde las voces que menos son escuchadas
las de los niños y las de las niñas yo
estudiantes visuales
me especialicé en el uso de la cámara
todo el tiempo quiero estar filmando y
produciendo pero también quiero hacer
historias de ficción documental
animación creemos que el cine es una
herramienta fantástica para transformar
y educar las sociedades y bueno cuando
comenzamos los talleres también se dio
la coincidencia que comenzamos con
nuestra etapa de papá y mamá y creo que
también tenía que ver que nos interesaba
conocer las verdaderas necesidades de la
infancia pues para poder educar a
nuestro a nuestra hija y bueno a mí
muchas personas me dijeron que tenía un
talento muy natural y una sensibilidad
para trabajar con los niños y con las
niñas sin ser una educadora de formación
si por mi parte todo lo contrario a mí
me desesperan mucho los niños
supongo que a la mayoría de todos
siempre están corriendo esos pequeños
individuos siempre están corriendo
moviéndose de un lado para otro
pero sobre todo siempre están
cuestionando todo y todo el tiempo
cuestionan lo que son ellos pero también
cuestionan lo que hay alrededor y si nos
ponemos a pensar un poco es el mundo en
el que vivimos
el mundo en el que vivimos que muchas
veces ven y conocen a través de los
medios de comunicación los medios de
comunicación que crean contenidos para
ellos pero las personas responsables
siempre somos adultas
de por si los medios masivos nos
consideran a todos nosotros como
inactivos frente a las pantallas y con
los niños pues el caso es aún peor ya
que niega la oportunidad que desde la
infancia desde quiénes son ellos generen
y tengan la oportunidad de hacer sus
propios contenidos y no solamente los
contenidos audiovisuales sino en todo lo
que los rodea si nos ponemos a pensar
las casas están nuestras casas están
diseñadas para que solo el hábitat en
los adultos y no los niños imaginemos
que dormimos en una cama gigante y que
al caer no nos podríamos lastimar fue lo
que no le pasó a nuestra hija mayor que
se cayó y se fisuró la clavícula o a la
hora de servirle los alimentos a los
niños les pongamos los platos los
anticipios a la altura de los ojos eso
es algo muy incómodo también pienso que
como sería si le pudiéramos dar a
nuestros hijos en la cocina las
herramientas para que ellos pudieran
hacerse desayunar podríamos hacerlo yo
he visto a mi hija más pequeña que lo
hace y así nos permite los fines de
semana a dormir unos 15 minutos más
también o más si se puede
se trata de reflexionar que cuando un
bebé nace o cuando un niño o niña llega
a este mundo llega a un mundo que es de
adultos y tiene que aprender el mundo a
partir de eso
si así sucede en la casa en donde de
repente podemos tener la elección de
adecuar a un inmobiliario más pequeño
imaginen el espacio público no ese
espacio que de todos modos las personas
adultas los niños las niñas hemos ido
perdiendo en algún taller hicimos un
ejercicio donde preguntábamos a los
niños cómo sería la calle ideal y algún
niño contestó que le encantaría que
hubiera cosas de chocolate no que
hubiera por ahí carros de chocolate
árboles de chocolate que todas las casas
fueran de chocolate y se pudieran comer
pero otra niña más seria comentaba que
le encantaría que en la calle
simplemente fuera segura para poder
jugar para poder caminar y haciendo así
varias reflexiones con ellos de hubo
quien dijo otras cosas también parecidas
a los de chocolate cosas muy fantásticas
pues en realidad pensábamos que era una
reflexión acerca de un lugar un espacio
mucho más amigable para ellos
y si precisamente en el que dices copio
es un espacio donde ponemos a
experimentar y explorar todas estas
posibilidades de hacer una participación
de colaborar y hacer ideas que puedan
ellos desarrollar y decir por medio del
cine
creemos que el cine es una herramienta
súper fantástica para conocer otros
mundos pero también para que ellos los
puedan crear
y también el cine es una herramienta
para poder conocer otras personas que es
lo que nos ha llevado nuestro taller a
conocer más personas en el estado y a
conocer más personas en nuestro país
me acuerdo de nuestro primer taller o
nuestro segundo taller que fue en
matamoros en el ejido la luz donde
conocimos a marta una gestora cultural
comunitaria y conocimos a doña cata una
facilitadora del conafe que nos llevaron
a su comunidad para trabajar con niños y
niñas que que están ahí y viven rodeados
como en muchos lugares de la frontera de
maquiladoras con problemas de salud y
ahí conocimos también abraham un niño
que le encantaba escribir historias
después el vino y adaptó la historia que
otra niña sugey le había contado su tía
acerca de un muñeco que cobraba vida
trabajamos todos juntos bueno abraham
hizo la historia para hacer la película
y luego trabajamos todos juntos en la
creación y en la grabación y en las
ideas para para ello
se llama el muñeco diabólico y es hasta
la fecha uno de los cortometrajes que
más disfrutan nuestras hijas del
caleidoscopio y si las historias de
terror es lo que los niños les fascina
supongo que a la mayoría también de
nosotros recuerdo un taller que vivimos
en aquí en ciudad victoria hicimos un
taller de animación donde les
preguntamos a los chicos y a las chicas
que que les parecía la escuela y ellos
decían que era muy aburrida no se puede
ser que sí pero dicen que se les hace un
poco aburrida porque no les toman en
cuenta no toman en cuenta sus opiniones
y tampoco toman en cuenta lo que quieren
decir también nos comentaban que siguen
las reglas que tienen que seguir unas
reglas y eso no está mal sino que no
saben por qué tienen que seguir esas
reglas recuerdo un taller que vimos en
san pedro garza garcía donde una chica
se acercó y dijo oiga profe por qué
porque no podemos aprender mientras
jugamos como lo estamos haciendo en este
taller y me puse a pensar que realmente
las escuelas no piden la opinión a los
niños sobre lo que quieren hacer
y bueno no es como criticar a la escuela
sino más bien es pensar que muchas veces
los niños y las niñas llegan a espacios
donde ya todo está concebido y no se les
pregunta su opinión sin embargo también
hemos trabajado en espacios donde haya
otras estructuras para educar me
recuerda mucho cuando estuvimos en san
cristóbal de las casas en chiapas
y llegamos a un lugar que se llama la
casa de las flores un albergue para
niños y niñas que van a aprender a leer
a escribir a jugar mientras sus papás o
mamás venden artesanías en el centro
histórico de san cristóbal o también
ellos mismos no van van a descansar o
también aprender a leer en esa casa
el primer día que llegamos no es una
casa como estas antiguas con un patio
interno muy muy grande pues lleno de
flores y nos recibe un niño muy curioso
nos observa
nos ve con nuestro equipo y lo primero
que nos dice es
a qué horas vamos a hacer la película y
si hicimos la película y haciendo una
reflexión de esto el cineasta jonas
mekas dijo que el cine no tiene que ser
perfecto y si lo ponemos en el contexto
de los niños y sabemos que los niños son
perfectos pero eso hace que hagan un
cine muy auténtico y muy sincero ahí
podemos ver de lo que se preocupan de su
entorno lo que les gusta lo que no les
gusta pero también sus preocupaciones
también podemos escucharlos ver qué es
lo que imaginan pero eso sí siempre
siendo muy sinceros con lo que quieren
decir haciendo un cine muy sincero que
algunos de nosotros los adultos
quisiéramos tener un cine como ellos un
cine muy auténtico
y unas miradas muy auténticas porque el
cine se trata de miradas y de las
miradas pues la de los niños y las niñas
son muy auténticos y en especial las
niñas como carod hijo en nuestro país
guía para nosotros en el caleidoscopio
las niñas tienen un lugar muy especial
porque las hemos visto con todas las
ganas de querer aprender a usar una
cámara de querer aprender a ayudar a sus
papás en sus trabajos en la milpa como
en la comunidad de saja y en el estado
de querétaro donde estuvimos con niñas
que eran bastante rebeldes y todo el
tiempo estaban cuestionando lo que
íbamos a hacer siendo de una comunidad
rural con niñas en la comunidad bolaños
cacho en la ciudad de mexico en la
colonia buenos aires que viven
encerradas en un multifamiliar porque a
sus padres les da miedo que salgan con
niñas aquí en ciudad victoria en la
colonia moderna o en el barrio pajaritos
niñas a las que vemos con muchas ganas
de aprender y de hacer
desde que terminar la secundaria y
esperar unos años para simplemente
casarse y no poder hacer nada más
si niñas rebeldes que no querían hablar
inclusive conmigo pero bueno al final ya
poquito a poquito haciendo la reflexión
trabajando y colaborando pudimos
trabajar recuerdo también un taller que
dimos en tampico en la colonia
pescadores donde se encontraba
ahora jorge y leo son adolescentes ya
son adolescentes si ellos querían hacer
un proyecto documental sobre su colonia
y ellos veían siempre a una mujer adulta
que pasaba por ahí era vecina de ellos
quería entrevistar la hicieron su
investigación fueron a buscarla
doña coti recuerdo el nombre de ella y
ella les empezó a platicar parte de su
historia de la colonia y algo que les
dijo era que en esa colonia se había
aparecido el
imagínense la señora platicándole los
niños aparte les dijo que el
estaba en forma de perro y que escupía
lumbre por la boca por los ojos por los
ojos entonces los niños estaban
fascinados contra él con el relato de
esta señora adulta ella sabía que lo
estaba haciendo intencionalmente para
poder pues estar con ellos presentes no
los chicos nada me miraron dijeron profe
vamos por las cámaras vamos por las
cámaras vamos por el tripe y el
micrófono y vamos a hacer la entrevista
pero le exigimos que tenemos que hacer
un guión primero
estaban muy prendidos con eso al final
hicimos como la reflexión de que
habíamos unido a los chicos con la
señora y por el medio de un ejercicio
audiovisual y que también habíamos
generado comunidad entre todas y todas
creo que fue una experiencia muy linda
que al final quedó registrada con con la
historia del coti y el
bueno ahí en los pescadores además de la
historia de doña coti contaron la
historia en tampico no sé si sepa no hay
es como esta leyenda urbana de una nave
espacial que está en el mar también
hicieron un cortometraje acerca de eso
de unos extraterrestres que llegaban y
les decían que no podían que cuidaran el
planeta no entonces hicieron varias
historias allí en la pescadores una
colonia que precisamente se llama así
porque los padres de la mayoría de esos
niños trabajan en la pesca
pero hay en realidad muchas historias
que podríamos contarles de cada uno de
los niños y las niñas con las que hemos
trabajado en nuestro estado y con las
que hemos trabajado también en otros
puntos del país historias que como decía
hace rato rodrigo representan su
imaginación sus sueños pero no siempre
todo es como tan bonito muchas historias
o muchas ideas que manifiestan las niñas
y los niños en los talleres también
manifiestan la influencia de los medio
de comunicación la influencia de su
entorno me recuerdo mucho en nuevo
laredo trabajamos un taller donde cuando
llegamos bajamos el equipo
los niños agarraron el tripié no este y
lo empezaron a utilizar como un
ametralladora
y para mí fue muy impactante porque era
un taller que estábamos dando al aire
libre en una plaza pública donde los
siete días que duró este taller una
camioneta del ejército mexicano
circundaba la zona entonces llegamos a
la reflexión que había una gran
influencia por lo que estaba sucediendo
en esos niños pero dijimos no el tripié
se pone aquí sirve para que una cámara
se ponga encima y para que tú puedas
tomar una fotografía a tu mamá a tu papá
a tu familia a tus amigos o puedes
grabar una película cómo fue lo que
hicimos con ellos entonces es importante
dar las herramientas y dar las
alternativas decir pues si de repente
para estamos en un lugar y en un
contexto de esta manera pero también se
puede hacer esto y si el caleidoscopio
surgió en el espacio o en un tiempo más
bien de un tamaulipas violento e
inseguro la propuesta de nuestro taller
es darle la herramienta a los niños para
que puedan reflexionar sobre lo que se
es pasa en su entorno que conozcan la
participación y la construcción entre la
sociedad pero también que conozcan sus
derechos
que sepan que son sujetos de derechos
eso es también lo más importante que
estamos viendo con ellos en los talleres
que vean alternativas para la cultura de
la paz para fomentar una cultura de paz
y que sí que sepan que son sujetos de
derechos a mí de repente en redes
sociales veo que mucha gente se molesta
porque se hable de derechos de las niñas
y los niños y se dice no ven lemas
derechos a los niños para crear personas
y responsables o egoístas etcétera pero
en realidad es que no no podemos darle
la espalda a la infancia en un méxico
con cifras de crimen y violencia en
contra de ella cada vez más elevadas en
un méxico donde las cifras de embarazos
adolescentes e infantiles también cada
día están a la alza nos alegra decir que
en esta tarea no somos las únicas
personas que trabajamos con niñas y
niñas desde un enfoque de colaboración y
participación donde dejemos que expresan
sus ideas y sean parte de la realización
de lo que quieren construir hemos
conocido maestras hemos conocido
compañeros colectivos en nuestro país
que están trabajando por ello con
diferentes herramientas en nuestro caso
es el cine y el lenguaje audiovisual
pero lo que queremos decirles a ustedes
hoy aquí personas adultas a los niños y
a las niñas es que si hay otra forma
posible de hacerlo
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
i